let us speak crystal-clear about the  choice  it is distilled of wax it not it might  not happen at all faced with this stark  reality members of the House of Commons  have a deep responsibility and the  fundamental fundamental choice to make I  was following day after day sometimes  minute after minute the debates in the  House of Commons interesting debates and  all the views which were expressed in  the debate have to be respected I am  convinced that the members of the House  are tactless and rightly so but I'm as  convinced that the members of the House  will have we want to have a good future  relationship with the European Union  if the with all agreement gets the  backing of the house the European Union  is ready to immediately begin  preparations on our future relationship  European Commission's negotiation teams  in place our tireless and his famous  skin - chief negotiator Michel down here  will be at the head of the street we are  ready